hello everyone this next game I prepared
for you is the game played between two
magicians the magician with the white
pieces is the Russian agent Dino and the
magician with the black pieces is Mikkel
Tao now this game was played in 1961 in
the USSR championship in Baku and well
not a lot of you know but Boris Spassky
actually won that event but well the
only thing people really remember from
that event is this game played between
Najma Tino and Tao now there's a certain
reason I chose this game even though
nature Athena mantle played four games
for official games altogether this is
well a couple of months after towel lost
his title as a world champion so this is
probably a towel in his prime and well
one more thing out of those four games a
talent is matino played and is matino
dubbed the white pieces in all four
games so the result is three to one in
energy matino favor but I'm interested
in what the result would be if Dahl had
the white pieces in at least two games
but nevertheless tall and nature matino
were actually very good friends the
first time Tom noticed Medina was in
1957 well it was also the USSR
championship and Michael towel won this
event but Russia denies matino as tall
says always gets the brilliancy prize
for an event defeated Michael Tao in the
1957 the USSR championship and this is
when him and towel became really good
friends so you know measure matino was
always hanging around with towel he just
can't come to his apartment and they
used to play blitz games you know long
into the night and drink some black tea
with vodka and well pal actually decided
to take his machine of it his second in
his championship metric and Botvinnik
and all those already had a coach for
opening preparation in theory it was his
old coach Alexandre Koblenz but he also
took engagement in overhanded well a lot
of people people were baffled by this
because as they said Rashid wasn't even
a grandmaster
but Sal said that those paradox
the receipt of presents presents him
with our great interest to him and
seeing his he thinks they were radius in
his match against Botvinnik well that
being said let's see this game between
these two magicians so Mitch Pitino is
white and towel is black there's Makino
plays efore Talgo c5 Knight to f3 d6 d4
C casters and e4 Knight captures on d4
the Sicilian defense Knight to f6 Knight
to c3 and now a 6 tall goes for the
Sherman Indian variation we have Bishop
to e2 Knight B to d7 energy between of
castles towel plays a 6-4 Queen to c7
and Arnage matino pushes with g4 so tar
goes b5 preparing to push b4 and MS
matheno prevents that a 3 so we have
Bishop to b7 by tau Bishop to f3
protecting that efore pawn towel place
nice to see v attacking d4 pawn again
and the net material defended with Queen
e2 and now tel pushes a 5 and in this
position is matino plays Knight to f5 it
looks like a very nice outpost for the
nice and since that towel out that why
not play this so towel plays g6 and then
is Matheny of place as captures on e5
immediately because now this Bishop is
hitting the h6 Square and it will be a
nice outpost for tonight and although
Tao could capture the night here with G
takes on f5 and then after it captures
on f6 f captures on e4 Knight captures
on e4
well black would probably have the
castle and whites does have an edge in
this position so towel didn't want to go
for this and since that also loves magic
tell plays D captures on e5 sown is
Makino plays in I to h6 and this pretty
much prevents black from ever castling
kingside so top plays Knight to e6
we have Bishop Lee
jeetu from an edge Medina Bishop to g7
and this is where majority no lunches
one of the greatest combinations and
wins the brilliancy prize for this game
Najma tino plays rook captures on f6 and
well there's really nothing to do here
except well take the rook
so imagine Athena plays Bishop captures
on f6 and now Nativity no place to 90 d5
and well you can't really capture the
night because if Bishop captures night
you would get he captures on d5 and
after this Knight moves
well this d6 move would be crushing so
uh 95 towel plays Queen to d8 protecting
this Bishop on f6 but now now Nash
matino plays Queen to f2 and now is
matheno is hitting that f6 Bishop twice
and well the bishop can't really move
because he's also attacking f7 if the
bishop moves so there's really not a lot
of things Kyle can do here maybe maybe
you think that stall can capture the
knight on d5 but this is actually what
happens if the knife is captured you
would get Bishop gate captures on d5 he
captures on d5 Knight for Bishop
captures on f4 e captures on f4 and
Quincy five and they feel like a
disposition the white rook is ready to
come to e1 with check this is quite
devastating so after Queen to f2 Michael
tells right at Knight to f4 immediately
so measurement Univ captures Bishop
captures on f4 e captures on f4 and now
this patina of continuous initiative
would be five and in this position you
might also get an idea that well why not
captured the knight now and if you did
so well if Bishop captures on d5 then
simply he captures on f6
and well there's really nothing but can
do here for you see if for example black
would play Bishop captures here then
well what you're going to do after Queen
c5 I mean this rook to e1 check
unstoppable so after so in this position
there's really nothing to do black would
simply have to capture this point on f6
and drop for this Bishop on d5
so after E 5 tile decided to play Bishop
captures on e5 and measurement Ino plays
rook to e1 attacking the pin piece so we
have f6 by tau and noun is mattina plays
Knight captures and s6 with check so the
bishop bishop cannot capture because
it's pinned and well it's checked so tel
plays Queen captures on f6 and here tau
plays Queen to d4 and well again you may
think that well okay why not capture the
bishop now but let's see what happens if
you capture the bishop now if Bishop
captures on g2 then rook the e5 check
King to f8 and now this g5 move would be
crushing the black Queen cannot defend
the f4 pawn anymore and wherever the
black Queen goes well Queen captures on
f4 which check will lead to mate in next
move so on Queen d4 towel played King to
f8 and in this position Russia played
rook captures an e5 we have Queen to d8
trying to exchange Queen and now another
beautiful move banished matino
measurement in the place looked at v
check and open up opens up the attack
and this rockin a chaise so it all has
to capture G captures on f5 and now
Queen captures on h8 we have king te
seven Queens the g7 check topless King
to e6 and 19 of plays G captures on f5
would check and in this position mikhail
tal resigned because well there's really
nothing to do here it's forced mate in
eight but well analyzing it would
wouldn't really make sense because after
G captures on f5 King 36 you could get a
nice f7 check and this already into the
king and the Queen and the well you can
do the rest by ourselves if you really
want to so yeah very nice game between
two magicians
and very nice all of the games between
these two players were great and even
though Nash Medina warned the three
games and Michael tal one only one like
I said I would be very interested to see
how how things would go if tall had the
white pieces and one other thing I would
really like to see is those blitz game
they were playing if someone actually
kept note of the games and yeah after
Rasheed's death Michael Dahl was very
sad and well he said he wrote in his
obituary that tau was very glad that
Nash matino chose Latvia the place to
play his last tournament and he didn't
want the tournament 1901 a third place
but as always he took the brilliant
surprise with him but I will put the
entire letter in D of the obituary in
the description below so you can so you
can read those words about Rashid so
yeah this is the game I hope you enjoyed
it and I'll see you soon